mais des fois on reste un bout sans y
penser parce que quand il repense c'est
vraiment difficile on absorbe un peu
compte gouttes ce qu'on peut habiter ce
qu'on peut un matin disent ils ont été
réveillés berliner et 20 mai mais
voisins voisines et amies voisins on
s'est réunis ici parce qu'on a un bon
point de vue la mairie fasse qu'habite
face aux musiques a fait rêver un
commerce une boutique de linge face aux
musiques a fait état dans un bâtiment
dont immédiatement de penser à notre
sabre ses communiqués pour the way
mairie france donc avec mon voisin on
est allé voir à son chalet on aurait
aimé qu'elle soit décider lequel est
décidé d'aller toucher son chèque soit
là mais non et finalement durant la nuit
2h 3h 4h dans le groupe s'il en est
c'est toute la famille qui était
essayeur même aussi qu'ils aiment la
france vous apparaît dans quelques
minutes
donc moi aussi ça il faut se rendre à
l'évidence qu'on a jamais eu de preuve
de son corps n'ont jamais trouvé parties
de son corps on avait compris ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas la revoir
n'est juste pas avoir de preuves
concrètes que vraiment c'était fini
c'est toujours été depuis on espérait
toujours comme pour un miracle et si je
vous demande ce que la tragédie a changé
chez vous pas vraiment fait un test sur
la personne goûter mais ça te fait sa
demande à quel point tu es fort puis
malgré le fait que une tragédie tu es
quand même toi vivants qu'ils étaient
capables de terre neuve
et continue ta vie ça a vraiment montré
des côtés nous mêmes que l'on
connaissait pas développer la résilience
qui a tout le monde nécessaire pour se
relever
l'accident est arrivé tissot de l'armée
ont cherché des solutions on peut pas
accepter ça puisse arriver et on va s'en
sortir avec strass puis je nous souhaite
le pardon pour pardonner l'événement ce
qui s'est passé l'année passée puis
continuer avec la tête haute